Ron you've been sweating in here all day
are you drinking any fluids yes plenty
no you need to drink water usually I
take it neat
but I will make an exception in the name
of Health last night I watched a movie
with Diane and the girls in which an
orange fish is separated from his father
the children were sniffling which I
believed to be due to the sad nature of
the film I was wrong you need to take
off those layers rehydrate and go to the
doctor thank you for your concern I will
be fine
please turn the thermostat up to 90 and
leave me alone Ron this isn't safe I'm a
grown man I have had a cold before I
need no help so if you don't mind that
seems about right
I'd like to object again to being
brought here against my will
okay I'm just gonna double-check your
form here Ron you redacted all the
information answered some of them for
date of birth you wrote springtime which
is true everything you write down is
confidential we need you to give real
answers fine
how many drinks of alcohol do you
consume a week one that's it one drink
one shelf do you exercise yes lovemaking
and woodworking do you have any history
of mental illness in your family I have
an uncle who does yoga allergies
cowardice and weak-willed men and
hazelnuts sexual history epic and
private okay I'm gonna go get your
doctor he's a rude brash jerk you'll
love him before you begin a few ground
rules I need you to explain everything
you do before you do it so I can
determine whether I will allow you oh
yeah balsa wood you could at least use
mahogany there's something occluding
your ear
it's sawdust just blow oh you got strep
throat running your prescription for
penicillin
we'll have the rest of your test results
in about 20 minutes cholesterol I'm
interested good day
wheesh all patients were like that it's
really annoying when they ask questions
hey you look better I guess actual
medicine can be effective who'd have
thunk please leave me alone not until we
go over your test results and your blood
work your blood pressure looks fine not
sure how this is possible but your
cholesterol is 120 which is the lowest
I've ever seen what's cholesterol and
the only problem I see is that your
potassium's low so just eat a banana
once in a while
No thank you I live the way I live I eat
the things I eat and I'll die the way
I'll die that's oddly beautiful but also
stupid you're not alone in the world
anymore Ron you're dating a woman who
has two kids so every three days think
about ivy and Zoe and Diane and eat a
damn banana
hey Ron hey Ron ladies
you